Sean Spicer you brought him up I have to
ask you knew this guy before yeah you
knew him before he was a communications
director and a senior strategist at the
Republican National Committee very well
regarded by journalists within within
Washington DC I had a very good
relationship with him a lot of people in
journalism I know did I think a lot of
us don't necessarily recognize the guy
that we see on the podium now yeah it's
unbelievable that the guy you knew
before is now being caricatured by
Melissa McCarthy on Starnet live it's
just kind of it's like it's again you're
saying that he has had to change his
personality to assert his personality
but he now has to defend things that he
would never say and and things that he
would never do here's a perfect example
you could see glimmers of Shawn when
after the president put forward this
ludicrous crazy theory that three to
five million illegal votes had been cast
right and that was the only reason that
he didn't win the popular vote because
god forbid he ever not win something and
it'd be his fault
it had to be a great grand conspiracy
there's no evidence of this is there
evidence of individual incidents of
voter fraud across the country yes three
to five million No zero and there's not
one Republican elected official worth
his salt who will back that or Democrat
so when Spicer was asked about this the
next day at the briefing he said well
that's the president's belief almost as
if we was saying you know that's the
president's religious belief how you how
you could how dare you question yes he
believes that we pray to a giant frog
God named Gort and who are you to say
that Gort is not God right right this is
the president's bully
[Laughter]
let's see I'm aboard he in as well I
wish we could talk more you got to come
back or at least we'll have dinner and
I'll get to see that face staring at me
across the table every time I suggest
another dinner
you